Nuestra gran creación, la que
nos hace más ricos, más inteligentes,
más ecológicos e incluso más felices.
Así es como Edward Glaeser, catedrático
de economía de la Universidad de
Harvard, describe la ciudad.
Atenas, Roma, Venecia, Londres o Nueva
York, la ciudad siempre ha tenido un
papel destacado en la historia del
hombre
y hoy más de la mitad de la población
de todo el mundo se concentra en estos
espacios.
Pero, ¿cuáles son las ciudades que más
que crecen? Hoy en VisualPolitik
contestamos a esta pregunta.
Las ciudades estimulan la colaboración entre las
personas, la especialización
productiva y la difusión de las ideas.
Se puede afirmar que ya desde Jericó, la
ciudad más antigua de la historia, el
concepto de crecimiento económico es
fundamentalmente un concepto urbano.
No obstante es en las ciudades donde se
han desarrollado la práctica totalidad
de las innovaciones que han generado la
evolución del ser humano.
Por eso no es extraño que la
concentración de la población mundial
sea una tendencia creciente
según datos de la ONU mientras en 1950
el 30% de los habitantes de la tierra
vivían en ciudades, en 2015 era el 54%, casi 4.000 millones de personas,
sin ir más lejos la última gran crisis
la de 2008 ha afianzado el poder las
grandes urbes como centros económicos y
desde entonces muchas grandes
metrópolis han logrado alcanzar un
crecimiento vertiginoso. En Estados
Unidos, por ejemplo, tan sólo siete
áreas metropolitanas Nueva York, Los
Ángeles, Chicago, Washington, Dallas y
Filadelfia suponen el 25% de todo el
producto interior bruto nacional.
El Instituto americano brookings presentó en 2015
un estudio sobre las trescientas urbes
más grandes del mundo, con este estudio
perseguía determinar cuáles eran las
ciudades que más estaban creciendo. Trató de fijarse para ello en dos
elementos: el crecimiento económico per
cápita y la capacidad para generar
empleo de cada ciudad. Cabe decir que estas
trescientas urbes con apenas el 20% de
la población de todo el mundo generan
casi la mitad de la economía mundial.
Conforme al estudio del Instituto Brookings éste es el particular top five de
las ciudades más prósperas.
En quinta posición se sitúa Dubái,
una de las pocas ciudades desarrolladas
en los puestos altos del ranking.
Dubái ha logrado abandonar la
dependencia del petróleo y convertirse
en un centro financiero y comercial a
escala mundial
al tiempo que es también un gran hub
logístico. Para hacernos una idea de sus
logros cabe decir que en la actualidad
Dubái está ampliando su capacidad
aeroportuaria para alcanzar los 220
millones de pasajeros anuales, el doble
de los que mueve el aeropuerto más
grande del mundo, el de Atlanta.
Dubái es famosa por sus excesos en
formas de pistas de esquí en el
desierto, islas artificiales y los
rascacielos más altos.
Las siguientes tres posiciones están
ocupadas por ciudades de Turquía
ciudades que han conseguido aprovechar
el boom económico que el país turco
registró entre los años  2009 y 2014.
Así, en cuarta posición se sitúa Bursa,
también conocida como la Detroit
turca, y es que la ciudad se configura
como un gran 'cluster' de la automoción
donde se realiza el 60 por ciento de la
producción nacional. Empresas
internacionales como Renault o Fiat tienen
una destacada presencia en esta ciudad.
En tercera posición se sitúa Estambul,
la mayor área
metropolitana del país
y conocido centro turístico, comercial
y logístico. Punto de encuentro
histórico entre Asia y Europa
esta ciudad supone el 25% de toda la
economía turca.
En segunda posición la también ciudad turca de esmirna
situada en la costa del mar egeo a sido desde el siglo XVII considerada como un
puertas estratégico, hecho del que se ha
valido para convertirse en un importante
polo industrial. Desde la crisis de 2008
es la segunda ciudad del mundo donde
más rápido ha crecido el empleo.
Finalmente, en lo más alto del ranking,
encontramos a la ciudad autónoma de
Macao, la gran capital mundial del juego
"- me parece que llevo cuatro millones de euros aquí; - no está mal, me gusta este juego"
Sí, así es, Macao desplazó ya en 2006 a Las
Vegas como la capital mundial de los
juegos de azar y en 2014 llegó a
multiplicar por siete toda la
facturación por juego de Las Vegas
El juego en Macao ha llegado a mover 44 mil millones de dólares al año.
Sin embargo, desde que el Instituto
Brookings presentó su estudio, la
economía de Macao se ha enfrentado a un
auténtico colapso económico. El exceso
de inversión, la crisis en china y la
guerra que las autoridades de este país
han desatado contra la corrupción y el
lavado de dinero han propiciado que el
producto interior bruto de Macao cayese
en 2015 cerca de un 25%; si como lo
escuchais, prácticamente la misma
caída que Estados Unidos registró en
los cuatro años siguientes a la crisis
del 29.
Precisamente para tratar de relativizar
este tipo de fenómenos burbujísticos
hemos querido fijarnos también en las
ciudades que más han crecido desde que
comenzase el siglo, las ciudades más
prósperas desde el año 2000.
Con un crecimiento anual medio del 11% de su
pib per cápita y del 10% en el número
de empleos, lidera el ranking mundial
la ciudad china de Dongguan. Situada en
el entorno de influencia de Guanzu, esta urbe,
con más de ocho millones de habitantes,
es conocida por ser una de las fábricas
del mundo.
Además, esta ciudad se caracteriza por
un gran contraste demográfico y es que
la relación de mujeres y hombres es de
tres a uno lo que permite que nos
encontremos con noticias tan
sorprendentes como ésta
"la ciudad china donde los hombres
tienen hasta tres novias porque hay un
montón de chicas.
Un hombre llegó a explicar en la
televisión local que es más fácil
encontrar una novia que un trabajo. Un
obrero de fábrica
dice que tiene tres novias y que incluso
se conocen entre ellas."
Le siguen en el top five las ciudades de Jinan,
Suzhou, Xiamen y Wuxi; todas ellas
ciudades chinas, lo que pone de
manifiesto el gran boom económico que
ha registrado este país.
De hecho tenemos que descender hasta el
puesto 35 para encontrar la primera
ciudad no china: Dubái.
De esta forma, Dubái, Ho Chi Minh, Abu Dhabi
Delhi y Kuwait forman el top five de las
ciudades que más han crecido fuera de
china desde el año 2000.
Puede que algunas de la ciudad de las
que hemos hablado nos resulten
completamente desconocidas, pero lo
cierto es que hay un mundo en marcha que
cambia rápidamente. Dentro de unos años
es más que probable que muchas de estas
ciudades sean tan famosas como lo son hoy
Nueva York, Londres o Tokio. Un saludo y
hasta el próximo video.